it is important to be able to look into
the eyes of a man and say I am here and
recognize that this is from eight years
ago this is this woman her name obiad
shinoy uh this is her talking about John
Stewart's interviewing her and you'll
recognize a couple other people on the
panel uh talking about what her
intentions are when she gets a film in
her hands what is the balance of
activating a force for
change but also trying
to permeate that patriarchy that power
structure and is that a part of the
calculation of your art as well and and
what's been the reaction to that oh
absolutely um I like to make men
uncomfortable I enjoy making men
uncomfortable not you just just not not
you point taken point
taken but um you know it is important to
be able to look into the eyes of a man
and say I am here and recognize that and
recognize that I am working to bring
something that makes you uncomfortable
and it should make you uncomfortable
because you need to change your attitude
and it's only when you're uncomfortable
when you're Shifty when you have to have
difficult conversations that you will
perhaps look at yourself in the mirror
and not like the reflection and then say
maybe there is something wrong with the
way I think or maybe there is something
wrong with the way I am addressing this
issue Andy I remember when I was 5 years
old the first time I saw Star Wars and I
went into the bathroom after and I
stared in the mirror for like an hour
and I said you're a horrible person Dave
you're you're a boy here you're just
ter they're killing everything and by
the way John Stewart come yeah you got
to break the patriarchy like what a cuck
that's what they say a cuck
yeah so my reaction after seeing some of
these interviews of this um female
director I wasn't familiar with with her
before is um you know the the arrogance
that one has to have to feel um that to
be quite openly careless
about they're they're handed she's been
handed this Legacy of this film
franchise that has taken decades and
decades to build has millions of fans
around the world I mean personally I I
I'm not a Star Wars fan so I it doesn't
personally mean a lot to me but I know
through friends and throughout people my
in my life growing up how much it has
meant to them and you know well we
haven't seen the film that um you know
and we won't for a long time until it
comes out what she ultimately makes but
people should be concerned that somebody
who has this history of saying these
things of having a a political
philosophical agenda in her work work is
now been handed this huge franchise with
this Legacy um I just think first off
that it's it's really hugely
disrespectful to the fans and I think um
it it I mean it it speaks to the the Le
the lack of leadership I think from
Disney and how they've handled huge um
uh you know their brand I mean we we saw
with how with the live action of Snow
White with their their lead for the um
Snow White actress saying all these
things essentially um crapping all over
the the the first Disney film that made
uh Disney that made Disney have the
Legacy it have today for her to dismiss
it in these interviews about um uh how
it was essentially a bad film and that
Snow White was a bad character it's uh
you know so we see the arrogance coming
from not just actors and films which is
unfortunately to be expected but also
from
directors and by the way Disney
announced a few years ago when they got
both Star Wars and Marvel that they were
going to push Star Wars to be more for
young girls and the Marvel Universe to
be more for young boys so they that is a
type of social engineering isn't it
Colin yeah absolutely they this is all
part of like a a bigger pattern that you
see like happening in so many different
institutions where they take an
institution that has this Legacy this
history this earned Prestige and then
the activists just at the 11th Hour hop
in the driver's seat commandeer the
whole thing just to use as a megaphone
to spout their own ideologies and you
know undermine the entire Legacy uh
that's there we see this with the ACLU
we see we're seeing this with Harvard
how you know all this Prestige they had
now they're just you know spouting
racialist ideologies uh Star Wars is
doing this now we've seen medical
institutions do this this is just part
of the broader you know activist
Narrative of sort of taking over the
institutions uh and commandeering them
to their own ends and uh yeah I think I
mean this is a pattern that we're seeing
and it's it's going to keep going and
hopefully we can start pushing back
against this and I think again at the
box office this is where ultimately it's
going to uh it's going to get the push
back that it deserves right the push
back is the key part so I mentioned this
was there were some wins so it's a win
for Claud Dean gay to have resigned I
think there's a reaction win in this
Star Wars story there was nobody out
there like this is a great idea
everybody was pushing against it we'll
see ultimately what the movie will look
like